we've had some some good wind some wild
winds you know throughout my 12 years
but against a good football team on the
road you know that that ranks up there
that was good good win
he loves being on the football field
less practice loves everything about it
I think that is the energy that the team
feeds off of you know they they know
that and you know the Shawn's the type
of guy with a guy like the Shawn a
quarterback your team feels like they
have a chance to win every game they
play
huge challenge coming up here this
weekend
Oh Jerry Jones happy to be standing
there amid all those cameras and
microphones after getting the first win
in four weeks Cowboys very much alive
for the NFC he's crown Sundy statement
draft time trivia question outcome
determines who gets the first pick and
here's the question Travis Kelce
surpassed 1000 receiving yards yesterday
for the fourth time in his career only
three other tight ends in history have
for 1,000 yard seasons in their careers
name two of them really named two of
them well one's Tony Gonzalez shocker
and then well I'm gonna say kelan kelan
Winslow was gonna be in there Gronk I
know I don't know why I didn't I was
gonna say it I don't know what I
chickened out for I just took it down
all right well then you chickened your
way right into me getting the first pick
in the sunday statement draft and look
for a lot of those idiots yes I agree
for a lot of these games and a lot of
these players there are consequences for
the current year yeah for some players
there are consequences for next year
right and Jameis Winston he's doing
everything he can to make his case to be
the Buccaneers quarterback yes he 2020
how about 458 passing yards just he had
300 in the first half four touchdowns
and only one pick he started the game
with an interception on the first drive
put that behind him four touchdowns 458
big statement from Jameis Winston as he
lays the foundation to have at least one
more year as the Buccaneers quarterback
and who knows maybe they will iron out
these issues maybe another off season of
working with Bruce Arians who encouraged
him to do the virtual reality maybe
he'll take to the virtual reality all
offseason long and stop making dumb
mistakes if he can iron out the dumb
mistakes
the Buccaneers could be very good they
potentially gonna finish here nine and
seven and make the playoffs yeah no I
mean Jameis Winston and I feel like we
talked about at least once a week but
yeah his good is great I mean he
has superstar potential as far as the
good side of him and you know yeah
there's there's the bad though that
rears its head even last week in a game
where he threw what four touchdowns
three interceptions and still comes
through that way but agreed with you he
is making a strong case to come back
there at least on a one two year deal
something along those lines where yeah
they pay him and then maybe they protect
themselves that second year where
they're not stuck with a huge salary cap
charge if he finishes the year strong
enough though does he land on some other
teams wish list i I mean maybe I would
kid you guy Jon Gruden want him I don't
know no there's no way Jon would trust
Jameis Winston I just don't see that
happening I don't but but yeah I don't
know he's the first player ever 150 or
more yards passing him back-to-back
games
Wow about that first ever ever that's
how it's a lie that's that so so it may
be wrong okay okay all right he might be
right he might be right I'm not sure if
it was me you'd say well he might be
right I just feel like Brady did it one
time and I feel like actually my father
did it another time too so that's why I
want to say 450 yards in a season he
threw for 513 in a game and then came
back at the I know it was pretty good
it's pretty good it was pretty good yeah
but that you're his son makes me feel
sorry about that but I'm with you with
Jameis that was a statement for him and
I think he will be back as the Bucs
quarterback next year all right I know
you guys love this I know you love it
but I'm picking the whole Dallas Cowboy
[Music]
Jerry Jones Stephen Jones what's the
other Jones's name I can't remember
right now Jerry Jones June yes okay
there we go I knew I was missing some of
them I can't remember everybody but I
really do think this is one time that
justifies me picking the whole
organization I mean the Cowboys defense
was dominant we saw the Rams and we all
thought oh the Rams have kind of figured
some things out here in the last few
weeks they got it rolling they totally
shut down Shaun McVeigh's offense and
Jared Goff and girly I mean they were
non-existent and then the Cowboys
offense on that side of the ball was
just
from the get-go I mean pure physical
domination execution surgical whatever
you want to say
I thought Ezekiel Elliott looked amazing
dak Prescott played really good
you know Tony Pollard showed up just
good play design everything about the
game was domination the Rams were out of
this one halfway through the second
quarter we knew it was over and you were
going I don't think there's any way that
this is gonna be a football game and
Dallas kind of kept their foot on their
throat and really the this the score
doesn't even it's a lie I mean it's 37
to 7 midway past the midway point of the
fourth quarter and you know the the Rams
got a too late cheap touchdowns and
really added to their points and their
statistics from that yeah I agree with
picking someone from the Cowboys someone
specific from the Cowboys not the entire
organization it was hard to go say today
would you have chosen specific Prescott
because he was I think it was on him
right just to settle everything down and
make it work yeah right and he still got
the contract kind of riding on it and I
saw but but or Zeke yeah yeah Kersey
yeah ok all right I'm gonna go with
Julio Jones and here's why yeah here's
why he had 13 catches 434 yards and two
touchdowns yesterday it was his first
receiving touchdown since week three he
had not been over a hundred yards since
the bye week they had all those great
games since then they're four and two
since the bye he did not have more than
91 yards receiving in any game since the
bye week it says it's it's his number
two game of the year from a yardage
standpoint but 152 came in a loss to
Seattle 13 for 134 in the biggest win of
the year to go to San Francisco and take
down the 49ers big game for Jones who
got the big contract right before the
start of the season may have saved Dan
Quinn for another year and it's just
amazing to think of what the Falcons
could have been if they hadn't started
the season with a game at Minnesota that
they lost then week three they were at
the Colts that was not an easy place to
win and they had the Titans which was
not an easy team and I had the Texans
and it was a disaster to give up 53
points but you take a few of those games
you turn them from wins two losses
losses two wins and this is a team that
really
would have been in the thick of things
yeah and it's unfortunate but there's
enough there that maybe just maybe
Arthur Blank decides to let it ride for
one more year yeah no I mean it'll be
interesting to see what they do there
they're certainly some town on a Falcons
football team you know I think one thing
they got to worry about a little bit in
the offseason is depth of their team
because it's two years in a row we're
just a few injuries really throw them
off kilter for a number of weeks before
they kind of figure out how they're
gonna play going forward but you know
that was a very impressive win by them
and you know it makes you wonder again
you know it taught me a lesson yesterday
be careful about picking games and
betting games or anything like that
when there's common knowledge of
opponents you know Shanahan coming from
lying underneath Dan Quinn you know
Raheem Morris who coached under Shanahan
in Atlanta and was the receivers coach
now he's on the defensive side of the
ball it just shows you sometimes those
guys know a few little tricks of the
trade of what a guy does to attack a
certain scheme or whatever and they made
life hard on that 49ers offense a team
yesterday for sure I'm going with Steve
spagnolo as my statement second pick I
mean just again I don't you know the
Kansas City Chiefs where it's always
awesome to talk about Patrick mahomes
and Kelsey and Tyree kill it's awesome
and a man that there's no you know
watching Patrick mahomes is amazing but
the Kansas City Chiefs defense has
turned the corner really ever since that
Tennessee Titans football game which I
would say they even did some good things
then but you know you know there's this
game of three points it's nine points
with the Raiders so what was it against
the Patriots with 16 points 11 the only
two five points per game in a poor in a
four-game win that just says it all
right there I mean they're they're
showing that they can you know stop the
run they can do some really creative
things in the backend to take away
things you want to do in the pass game
steve Spagnola deserves a lot of credit
he's got that defense on track to where
now the Chiefs are dangerous because you
go if they do have a bad day offensively
which a bad day for them is still like
24 points they can win the game because
the defense is capable of making some
stops and causing some turnovers when I
talked to Pat from Holmes yesterday I
said do you kind of like it that
everybody seems to be sleeping on
right now and he said I kind of do yeah
you know they they picked up some
confidence in other players on the team
and some confidence in their defense by
necessity when Patrick missed those two
games with the knee injury and it's all
kind of building - yep and who's gonna
peak at the right time who's gonna be
the team that's hot going into the
playoffs and you've got four straight
wins now for the Chiefs they had those
ugly losses at home to the Colts and the
Texans and you felt like they were
starting to lose their grip on being a
truly elite team now they're right back
there and I know they're there to know
against the Ravens on the Lamar Jackson
and I would not want to mess with them
in the playoffs ya know they're scary
they when they could play defense like
that and then you have the weaponry they
have on the offense and I think the
interesting thing is with like the
Patriots and the Ravens having the two
best defenses in the AFC there are tough
matchups for the the the Chiefs are
tough on them I should say with the
style in which they want to play and
it's hard to be aggressive in your face
man-to-man type team which the Patriots
and Ravens want to do when Patrick
mahomes is that quarterback with the
weaponry he has his disposal all right
the last one from me and look 2017 the
flavor of the month of the flavor of the
season was deshaun Watson 2018 Petrov
Holmes 2019 the marg acts and I think
2020 is gonna be calamari yeah and
calamari was great yesterday look Kenyan
Drake had a great statistical game there
you look at Kyler Murray's actual stats
219 passing yards but he averaged eight
point eight per attempt he had 56 yards
rushing but you know he led the way for
38 points and they took down his good
friend Baker Mayfield the number one
picks in the last two drafts and it was
the kind of wind that will help the
Cardinals build confidence they had lost
six in a row
you know they felt like a team that is
contending that is viable right but they
couldn't punch it through they had the
three-point laws to the 49ers
three-point laws to the Bucks they
played the 49ers close again they played
the steel as close with six losses in a
row that ends with the win over the
Browns the Browns the better team but
the Cardinals win and I think that puts
everyone on notice that next year we're
gonna be hearing a lot from calimary and
I am
and forward to that yeah oh he's special
and he was a big reason they got out to
a 14 nothing lean not only his throwing
but had a few big runs early on that
kind of setup and got the Mojo going and
then Kenyan Drake was awesome as well
but yeah you're right they seem to be
competitive even when they were losing
football games and Kyle Emery is the
real deal as far as I'm concerned my
last one I'm going with the Bills
defense the bills year I want to go to
home and that's a whole offense could
have played a little better josh are you
leaving out Josh I know hey just the
defense just the defense cuz when you go
into Pittsburgh and out Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh in Pittsburgh you deserve
some credit okay and that's what they
did a day out for Pittsburgh in
Pittsburgh they outperformed the
Steelers at their own game they said
okay you want to play defense and Smash
Mouth that's cool we're down with that
and that's what they did and that speaks
to their head coach Sean McDermott I
mean they were you know tough to move
the ball against and then of course
creating the turnovers they created
those are things we usually see the
Steelers do and said it was the bills
with just a few plays here and there
from their offense but I do think the
defense doesn't get the notoriety it
should it should it's one of the three
best defenses in football hope everybody
hope everybody took notice of it last
night all right quick break we are way
over when we get you're ready for Monday
Night Football the cults at the tight
out that Pat that they know who we did
the same talk calls it the Saints we'll
be right back
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports